with reaction former Obama economic
adviser Austan Goolsbee Fox News
contributor former White House press
secretary Ari Fleischer and former
deputy assistant to the president Fox
News national security strategist
Sebastian Gorka or you're sort of in the
middle here I know you disagree with the
president at times I know you agree with
him at times
George Bush who you work for he was
attacked in a pretty unrelenting way I
was certainly no fan of Barack Obama's
Austin knows that well but it's never
been this bad and you've made that
observation yourself the vitriol the
outright hostility the wit the
personalization of the attacks against
Donald Trump and the thing about it Sean
is the similar sounds to what the press
did during the campaign when they
underestimated Donald Trump and
therefore half the country and they
haven't learned from those lessons I
just think the press would be so much
better off if they dropped the vitriol
and just start to understand who he is
why he does what he does and to cover
him because he's the outsider but
there's so much part of the
establishment it's very hard for them to
break those traditions you know I I
always went very hard because I
disagreed Austin with the president's
policies President Obama I know you
liked him
I give you his economic statistics
almost every time you're on but I'm not
gonna go there the only time I really
went after Michelle Obama is when she
injected herself into the political
arena I can't believe anybody in this
country especially a first lady or
running for president at the time would
be saying for the first time in my adult
life I am proud of my country that's
very different than the attacks on
Melania Trump reading a book to kids
English is her fifth language and she is
being rataxes being attacked well look
she shouldn't be being attacked you know
if you had it to do over you might not
have had that one foray into going after
Michelle Obama you mostly talked about
the president not the first lady I first
time I thought that the family shouldn't
shouldn't really be the subject now I
don't think the president ought to be
attaching himself here to Scott Pruett
though I mean
you got a case where he's got a cabinet
official that seems to be abusing the
power of his office for his own personal
benefit
if if I were advising the president I
know he's your friend you should be
telling him to get as far away from that
as he can't because I don't think Scott
Pruett is could I be in his job I won't
stay focused the reason I am laying down
a gauntlet on this show tonight as hard
as I am tonight is that this is now
every single day they want to not just
deal ejido Mize a president disagree
with the president
there is nothing dr. Gorka in the minds
of people on the left that Donald Trump
can do right absolutely not you'd think
they'd learn their lesson on the day of
the election Sean when the whole
left-wing media without exception said
that Hillary Clinton will be the
president instead of learning from just
how wrong they got it they doubled down
and we've now experienced a
year-and-a-half of persistent lying when
they go on national television and
simply lie about the administration
about what they're doing look pew the
Pew polling company is not exactly an
arch-conservative polling company when
they say that the mainstream media has a
five percent positive coverage of the
president after the last year and a half
you know they've got a problem but they
refuse to address it and that's why CNN
is at the bottom that's why Alison
Cooper is failing
that's why nobody laughs at you know
Kimmel's jokes and he's not even making
the grade they're just not learning
they're doubling down but the good news
is Sean they're making themselves
totally irrelevant yeah agree all right
so Ari maybe in the sense I think dr.
cork is right but it's sort of
cumulative I mean I kind of feel like
I'm a little island here in the in the
news media landscape I'm not exactly in
the majority in my opinions but it's
almost like nobody even wants to give
this guy an opportunity nobody sees
three million jobs being created as a
good thing or lowering taxes as a good
thing we're securing the border even I
just don't understand if you
what Kate Steinle x' mother or father
wouldn't you think that this is an
important thing to do yeah there is such
a break in this country now between what
is the definition of news if you're a
conservative and the definition of news
if you're a liberal and liberal really
does include so much of the mainstream
media and especially their top editors
and producers who drive so much of this
but you know Sean the bigger point here
is I've heard reporters say so many
times if the Democrats complain about
what we're doing and the Republicans
complain we must be doing something
right and I'm here to tell you that when
all your customers are saying you're
doing something wrong then you're going
out of business and that's the problem
with the press they becoming valid only
to an increasingly small slice of
America and that slice reinforces what
it thinks when they read these outlets
and they just can't stand Donald Trump
we all as a nation be so much better off
if the press just told the news reported
the facts straight down the middle